hey yesterday I trended on Twitter
thanks for the signal boost as always
Media Matters the economy continues to
Teeter and another mass shooting takes
place in Philadelphia I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
I have a lot to get to today we're gonna
go through some basic economics and also
some basic job advice today because
apparently people don't understand
English they don't understand economic
arguments they would much prefer to
attribute beliefs to me that I don't
actually hold but the entire show won't
be about me
we'll also get to a lot of the other
stuff that's in the news including
Jeffrey Epstein apparently having a
broken bone in his neck that suggests
strangulation so good times out there
we'll get to all of that in just one
second first geopolitical tensions are
rising and just read the news or listen
to the show the yields on bonds are now
inverted and this is giving a lot of
people pause about the future of the
American economy and the global economy
and people are rushing to gold and
there's a reason they're rushing to gold
the gold prices are rising radically the
reason is because when there are
turbulent economic times people look to
precious metals as a hedge against
inflation and uncertainty that is a
smart thing to do if you're interested
in getting some of that hedge in your
portfolio then you should really be
looking at my friends at Birch gold I
know the folks at Birch gold I trust the
people at Birch gold they're really good
folks they've been on my show before you
can hedge against inflation and hedge
against uncertainty and instability with
precious metals my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
if you diversified you wouldn't be quite
so scared of what's going on in the
stock market these days 800 points are
up yesterday the company I trust with
precious metal purchases Birch gold
group
contact Birch gold group get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals see if diversify into gold and
silver makes sense for you their
comprehensive 16 page kit reveals how
gold and silver can protect your savings
how you can legally move that IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds and into
precious metals if that's something you
want to do to get your no-cost
no-obligation kit text been to 47 47 47
again text my name Ben to 47 47 47 go
check them out right now
okay so I'm gonna do something that I
rarely do here on the show I'm gonna
talk about something that I've said
previously on the show the reason that I
usually don't do this on the show is
because I feel like most of the stuff
that I say is fairly self-explanatory
well yesterday there's a clip from the
show and it went viral because this is
what media matters does what they like
to do is clip part of a clip and then
put it out there and then people react
on Twitter as they normally do because
as I have said Twitter is the boo box
right Twitter is the
place where someone has sinned and we
throw them inside the blue box
they made a boo-boo we throw them inside
the blue box we drop scorpions and we
drop snakes on them well yesterday it
was my turn in the blue box because
that's what Twitter is and Twitter is
also a place of dunking and being dunked
upon and so yesterday was a day of slam
dunks okay so what generated all of this
you may have listened to the show
yesterday and thought to yourself I
didn't hear anything particularly
controversial what exactly was the big
controversy about well the big
controversy was about something that I
had to say about Kamala Harris so we
were talking yesterday about bad
economic tax and we were talking about
the senator from California suggesting
that no one in America should have to
work two jobs in order to put a roof
over their head or to get ahead and I
was making a very simple point the
simple point was that the government
can't fix that that is not a government
problem that's a you problem now when I
say a you problem I'm using you problem
the way normal people use you problem
not it's a problem with you if you have
to hold two jobs to put a roof over your
head but that it's a problem you have to
solve right it is a problem within your
domain it is not a government problem it
is a you problem
in fact I'm very much in favor of people
working multiple jobs
I've worked multiple jobs every day
since I graduated law school in 2007 I
have worked multiple jobs as of three
years ago I was actually working five
simultaneous jobs I kid you not I was in
editor-at-large over at Breitbart I was
the editor of daily wire I was doing my
podcast I was doing two radio shows a
morning radio show and an afternoon
radio show right I was I was working a
bunch of jobs at one time in fact I
think that that's good I think that that
is a sign of ambition that you're
working multiple jobs in order to get
ahead the point that I was making on the
show is that you live in a free country
it's your choice and if you don't want
to work multiple jobs you don't have to
now there are consequences to that of
course if you have to work two jobs to
put a roof over your head and then you
don't work one of those jobs you're
gonna have to lower your costs right you
have a few choices if you don't want to
work two jobs one is you could simply
not take the jobs that pay you less
believing that you're going to get a job
somewhere else that will pay you more
maybe that works out maybe that doesn't
your decision hey possibility number two
you lower your costs and you take one
job many people do this possibility
number three you work two jobs in order
to put that roof over your
in order to get ahead in any case these
are your options and these are all you
problems right this is the way that you
solve your own life and you make your
own life better what they are not is
what Kamala Harris suggests and what all
Democrats apparently suggest which is
the fourth off the board option I'm
going to go to the federal government
and force them to put a gun to the head
of potential employers and pay me what I
want to be paid and that is not an
option because that is tyranny and when
Kamala Harris and all the other
politicians tell you that they are going
to fix a you problem
that they are going to fix a problem
that you have to solve yourself a
problem that requires a use solution
when politicians tell you they're gonna
fix that by somehow restructuring the
economy so you can work that $15 an hour
job at McDonald's and it will become a
$35 an hour job magically so you can put
that roof over your head that you want
they are lying to you it's not going to
happen
that's not how economic works there's
not a bunch of rich people sitting
around who have always been rich and who
are seeking to put their boot on the
throat of poor people in order to pay
them less that is just nonsense the way
people get ahead in the United States is
they work hard yes they work multiple
jobs sometimes they feel they need to
work multiple jobs sometimes they do
have to work multiple jobs but not
because they're being forced by an
outside actor to do that because these
are individual choices we make in a free
country where we have free consensual
exchange of goods and services and pay
and people are coming back at me
yesterday after I said all this and they
were saying something like well you know
what about bad working conditions
I'm not against private-sector unions if
you get together with all of the
potential employees and you say we're
not gonna work there good for you you
should absolutely you should strike so
that you don't have to work in asbestos
Laden conditions of course you should
strike so you don't have to work in coal
dust without any sort of protections but
if the idea is that government has to
come in and regulate all of this and
change the consensual relationships
between a person who wants to work in a
person who wants to pay them for that
work the answer is no the answer is no
we are a consent based free-market
system and we should remain so ok so
that is what I was trying to say
yesterday here's what I actually said
and then we will see how people on the
Left decided to take this as I'm
crapping all over poor people or
something which is absurd
getting desperate at this point and she
continues to try it out promises that
she can't keep she says nobody should
have to work more than one job in the
United States nobody should have to work
more like okay sure you know I find it
very interesting something about this
administration this president you know
he's going around crowing about how this
economy is doing so well
right oh the economy is great he says
right and they refer to the unemployment
numbers well yeah I'm traveling our
country let me tell you something yeah
people are working they're working two
and three jobs and in our America we
must agree nobody should have to work
more than one job to have a roof over
their head and food on the table
okay well the fact is that if you had to
work more than one job to have a roof
over your head or food on this table you
probably shouldn't have taken the job
that's not paying you enough that'd be a
you problem
also it is not true they've asked me so
they took that clip without the Harris
quote so it is very obvious that I'm
responding directly to Kamala Harris's
contention that we all must agree
meaning the government must agree that
you should only have to work one job to
put a roof over your head and I'm saying
no no that's not a government problem
that's a you problem meaning it's a
decision that you are going to have to
make about your own life and by the way
this is a message that is going to allow
people to make free decisions that is
going to add to income mobility it's a
decision that that to take your own life
under your own control and Kamala
Harrison politicians lie to you they do
it right left and center they tell you
that if you are not living the economic
life of your dreams that they're going
to fix this for you that they're gonna
make it all better for you and they're
gonna do so with the power of government
they are lying to you to get you to give
them money and power they are not gonna
fix your problems you are going to fix
your problems you're gonna be the one
who makes free decisions to make your
life better you're gonna cut costs
you're going to make sure that you're
not spending too much you're gonna take
that extra job on the side I'm honestly
I'm insulted by how many people in the
media on the Left decided to take that
last clip and then suggest that I am
looking down on people who work more
than two jobs as though those people can
simply quit and get one job that's not
what I'm saying what I'm saying is that
if you chose to take two jobs that's a
you decision that's a you decision and
of course it's a you decision it should
be
you decision in fact I'm very much in
favor of people taking more than one job
if it gets them ahead my dad when who's
first married to my mom would work
nightclubs at night he's a pianist he
would work night clubs at night and then
he would stuff newspapers in the morning
and then he would deliver food during
the day he'd worked three jobs again
I've worked multiple jobs literally my
entire career I'm very much in favor of
that but it's my decision to do that and
that is how people get ahead we should
be inspired by people who are working
multiple jobs because it's their a
decision we shouldn't treat them as
though they are victims of society
because they're working multiple jobs we
should treat them as free actors in a
free economy who are making free
decisions to make their life better
freely that's how we should be treating
people and that's what I was objecting
to but apparently that is a pin that's
apparently scorned for people who are
poor and so I tweeted out all of this
yesterday and put out a Twitter thread
explaining exactly what Media Matters
had done they cut off the part with
caramel Harris so that it sounds like
I'm just saying out of nowhere that you
should be able to quit your two jobs and
get one job and obviously that
opportunity is available to everyone or
something like that that is not what I
was saying and if that's what you heard
then I apologize that's what you heard
but that's certainly not what I was
saying in any case I tweeted out what I
meant I said the point I'm making of
course is that you cannot dictate that a
job pay you what you wish it paid you
that is obvious and why it is
foolishness for politicians to claim
that the economy can be structured to
force your desired level of pay from a
job you chose to take now people are
very angry at us because they do want
the utopian solution which is the
government comes in and restructures the
economy along Kamala Harris is desired
lines I said the answer to the problem
of taking a job that you feel under pays
you is to a not take the job as I
suggest here or be not live beyond your
means those would be the two decisions
or take that job and then you don't get
to whine about it you don't okay if you
freely take a job and then you take the
pay that comes up like they made clear
what they were paying you the day you
walked in this has been true for every
job I ever helped and yes I have taken
significant pay cuts in order to take
jobs that I wanted when I first got out
of law school I was working at a law
firm right I go into Harvard Law
everybody works at a law firm afterward
I've worked there for ten months and
then I hated it so much that I quit
that was a me decision and I chose to
take a job that paid me one
third of what I had been making before
again a me decision do I then get to
whine about the fact I was being won
paid one third of what I was no it was
my decision as I say this was perfectly
clear in context the comments
immediately follows a line from Camilla
Harris claiming that no one should have
to work two jobs and so obviously this
is what I was saying so people decided
that they were going to go nuts and take
it out of context because this is what
they do naturally AOC decided to do this
so we are now in what year two of AOC
kind of sniping at people and then
refusing to talk to them so there's an
open invitation to AOC anytime she wants
to discuss this or any other issue she
can come on the show this is not Kat
calling as she put it but she sort of
cat called me yesterday by her own
standards so she tweeted out one of the
most manipulative tactics plutocrats use
is convincing people that the systemic
issues we face are character flaws
instead of policy flaws it stopped there
for one second okay plutocrats like what
rule by the rich hey let me explain
something
I was middle-class the vast majority of
my life the vast majority of my life I
know people like to make up kind of fake
histories about where I came from and
all of us and the fact is that my father
and mother I was born in a two-bedroom
small house in Burbank on Ontario Street
okay and that small house had one
bathroom and six people in it I shared a
bedroom with three sisters until I was
11 years old
hey we were middle middle-class we were
certainly not upper-class who are
certainly not rich and you know what my
parents worked their ass off to make it
so that our life was better and good for
them and they did so by working multiple
jobs they did so by making personal
decisions and she says one of the most
manipulative tactics plutocrats use so
I'm a plutocrat because I so again it's
plutocracy if I wish to preserve free
exchange between people but it is not
hierarchical rule from above that the
AOC wants to take a gun run by the
government and put it to the heads of
employers so top-down centralized
control by people like AOC is not
tyranny its tyranny if I say that there
should be free exchange between people
and how they choose to do jobs and she
says that one of the most manipulative
tactics plutocrats use is convincing
people that the systemic issues we face
our character flaws instead of policy
flaws well no I'm not saying it's
character flaw to take two jobs
obviously I'm saying in fact that very
often it's a character benefited it's
it's an attribution of great character
what I am saying is that that is a you
decision it's a you problem that's what
it is
issues working people aren't dumb or
inferior obviously no one is saying they
are except for ASE who apparently
believes they're not capable of
negotiating their own salary they're not
capable of creating income mobility
they're not capable of working two jobs
to get ahead says nor are they why
insulin cost three hundred dollars or
huge companies pay starvation wages I'm
always confused by AO C's bizarre
understanding of economics she says
corruption is responsible for huge
companies paying quote unquote
starvation wages really is that
corruption or is that people choosing to
take a job with Walmart because that is
a free exchange you may not like what
Walmart pays good news you don't have to
work there again that would not be
Walmart's problem that'd be a you
problem
now you problem doesn't mean a character
flaw in you it means that you're not
wanting to work at a place in a free
country is something that is your choice
when I say you problem I mean a choice
made by you one of the most manipulative
tactics used by socialists is suggesting
that free decision-making by individuals
is actually the result of systemic
pressures that cannot be avoided other
than by people like AOC running your
life the tactic that the Left likes to
use is there's no income mobility you
can never rise you're being crammed into
this job against your will that you're a
victim of circumstance and therefore
give me all the power it's manipulative
and it's garbage and it makes people's
lives worse it's just it's gross and
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second but first let's talk for
a second about one of the ways that you
might be thinking about protecting your
savings that you might be thinking about
investing as we enter a turbulent
economic period so a lot of people are
skeptical of crypto currencies and I
understand that I mean crypto currencies
are new but basically the concept of a
crypto currency is simply online gold
I mean basically what a cryptocurrency
is is it is a limited currency exchange
that cannot be manipulated from the
outside by a centralized government so
if you are sick of watching central
banks manipulate interest rates and
quantitative easing and all of this then
you might want to take a look at crypto
currencies because
the technology of blockchain there can't
be inflation of these currencies and as
you've seen these things actually do
have real value some cryptocurrencies
have tremendous value well if you're
interested in protecting yourself
against the politics and vicissitudes of
central banks and governments then you
should be looking at eat auro eToro is
smart crypto trading made easy eToro
social trading platform has over 11
million active traders and facilitates
over 1 trillion dollars in trading
volume per year globally you can access
the world's best crypto currencies they
have 15 different coins available that
low and transparent fees try before you
trade with a virtual portfolio with a
$100,000 budget never miss a trading
trend with charts and pricing alerts
either I mean this is all awesome you
get to try it out it gets to see how the
market works before you even put your
own money into it and again they've got
the charts and the pricing alerts sign
up today at eToro dot-com slash Shapiro
that's et oro comm slash up hero eToro
comm slash reparo take control of your
own financial future and give it a try
give it a whirl again sign up at eToro
comm slash up here that lets them know
that we sent you okay so one of the
things that socialists and and now too
many Democratic politicians want to do
is tell you that problems that only you
can solve our solvable by them this is
the gig and it's not just politicians on
the left we heard this from Donald Trump
in 2016 that if you lost your
manufacturing job in Ohio it was the
fault of the Chinese and the Mexicans
and all you needed to do was place your
trust in Trump and he would somehow
return your job to the dyeing factory in
your town and by and large this has not
happened because it turns out that when
politicians say that decisions freely
made among human beings are bad and can
be fixed by them that is a gambit for
power and money and that's what Carla
Harris is doing just as Bernie Sanders
does they label a problem that we all
experience who the many of us have
experienced which is economic
shortcoming or economic deprival and
then they use that as an excuse to say
that they can restructure the system in
a better a more fulfilling way and
that's a lie it's a lie because the
collective intelligence of the American
public and yes the world public is
greater than any one politician
believing they know what you ought to be
paid or what a job ought to pay do you
think that you know aoc they're
complaining about the price of insulin
well she's free to start an insulin
company and
explain how by eliminating corruption
she has lowered the price of insulin and
this has allowed her to create enormous
wealth for herself and her employees she
can do that anytime she wants in fact if
she provides me with a great business
plan I'm happy to invest but I don't
think she has any intent of doing that I
think that she's shouting at the moon
just as Kamala Harris is shouting at the
moon and all that does is train the
American people in learned helplessness
so there is this theory of psychology
called learned helplessness and learn
helplessness basically suggests that all
animals including human beings all human
beings in animals that we can learn
helplessness that if you teach people
that there is no correlation between
cause and effect people stop seeing the
correlation and then learn helplessness
so this this experimentation was first
done by a psychologist named Martin
Seligman Martin Seligman did this
experiment the experiment went like this
he took basically two sets of dogs one
set of dogs he would he would
electroshock
the set of dogs every time they were
they every time they ate a certain food
for example so would eat a certain food
they'll get an electroshock for a
certain amount of time and this trained
them an aversion right the dogs would
simply stop eating the foods that they
would not be electro shocked they were
compared with another set of dogs and
this set of dogs was not correlated with
food they wouldn't put food there so the
dogs would simply be shocked seemingly
at random times then what they would do
is they would take that second set of
dogs shocked at random times and they
would put the food in front of them they
would start treating them like the first
set of dogs so every time the dogs tried
to eat the food they would electroshock
them it turns out the second set of dogs
had learned helplessness so they would
sit there and whine they wouldn't start
avoiding the food they would still go
for the food but then they would sit
there and whine then when they were
shocked because they were not capable
now of learning a version they were not
capable of learning to help themselves
well learn helplessness is a trait among
human beings - it's highly linked to
depression by the way if you teach
children if you teach teenagers they are
not in control of their own life if you
teach them that systemic forces out
there that we won't define are always
going to keep you down
and that nefarious corrupt people out
there we won't name them they're just
out there that they're trying to screw
you eventually people are not going to
take the actions that can actually help
them they are not going to learn
helpfulness
now there's another theory of learned
helplessness which is that the natural
state of human beings is actually
helplessness and that you have to learn
helpfulness you actually have to
actively train people in the
relationship between cause and effect I
tend to believe this theory because I
see it in my own kids kids don't
understand it cause and effect until you
teach it to them and they would rather
whine then learn cause and effect well
that means that as a society one of the
things we should be teaching is that
decisions in your control are the ones
that can make your life better you want
to better your life then start looking
at what's in your control instead of
giving power to politicians like Kamala
Harris or AOC to restructure the entire
economy along lines that they see fit
and which will not help you in the end
because the fact is people been trying
to restructure capitalism in the United
States for decades and guess what about
the same percentage of people in the
United States are still under the
poverty line after we spent 20 trillion
dollars in the war on poverty and the
the the great danger to the American
public right now is a sense of pervasive
helplessness that we are not in control
of our own lives and it is a lie we are
in control of our own lives now that
doesn't mean that every situation in
which we find ourselves is a pleasant
one it doesn't mean that we're not gonna
have to work jobs we don't want to work
it doesn't mean that we're not gonna
have to work hard or cut expenses or
make decisions to move it does mean
however that the decisions within our
control are the ones most likely to
impact our own lives and Kamala Harris
ain't gonna change that by bitching
about people working two jobs that's not
going to change anything
in fact the only obstacles that need to
be removed for people are not the
obstacles of other human beings who you
should respect as independent human
beings negotiating with you now the
other obstacles are people who are
getting involved in the process I got an
email yesterday from somebody who had
seen this clip online and the email was
that they're in Boston and they were
saying well you know my wife and I we
make one hundred and seventy thousand
dollars combined per year and we have
three kids and we live in a house and
they're in daycare and we're still
finding it hard to make ends meet and
we're working multiple jobs Kym a
response to that is number one good for
you
number two the reason you're finding it
hard to make ends meet in Boston is
because the tax rates are exorbitant the
regulations are exorbitant and it's
almost impossible to find housing in
Boston if you actually want a better
world for
people making decisions freely of their
own accord then you need government out
of this business not in this business
you don't need Kamala Harris healing
things you don't need Kamala Harris
ratcheting up the taxes you don't need
Kamala Harris putting down markers on
how many condos can be built for
affordable housing what you need is them
out of this you need more free exchange
not less free exchange you want jobs
that pay better wages well you need is
more competition in the employment
market you need to make it easier to
start a business you need to make it
less burdensome to start a business the
fact is by the way that these minimum
wage regulations push by Democrats
largely help some big businesses at the
expense of small businesses small
businesses have lower profit margins so
the point that I am making here and have
been making consistently on this show
forever and throughout my career is that
decisions are in your own hands and if
you are given a choice between a problem
being a you problem and being a
government problem you should certainly
prefer that it be a you problem because
you are the solution not government not
Kamala Harris you and taking me out of
context to pretend that when I say that
a you problem is because you're lesser
no it's a me problem - it's an everybody
problem we are all individuals making
free decisions and those problems are
solvable if we put our minds to them if
we make solid decisions it's not up to
Kamala Harris to fix everything and by
the way it is not scorn for people to
treat them like adults
it's scorn for people to treat them like
children and suggest that your political
solution is going to fix their lives
when it ain't Elizabeth Warren ain't
coming in on a white horse to fix it
Kamala Harris ain't coming in on a white
horse to fix it Donald Trump ain't
coming down a white horse to fix it in
fact every time they tried to fix it
they make it worse in a second we're
gonna talk about the question of whether
it is actually true that the American
Dream is dead so one of the premises
that is being used by so many folks on
the left in all of this is that it that
you lack individual choice your
individual agency is gone because the
American Dream is dead because the
plutocracy has taken over
I'm explain why this is objectively
false in one second first when the
founders crafted the Constitution the
first thing they did was to make sacred
the rights of the individual to share
their ideas without limitation by their
government that's the first amendment
the second right they enumerated was the
right of the population to protect that
speech and their own persons with force
that would be the Second Amendment and
also in many ways the most important
Amendment I love the Second Amendment I
particularly loved these days when I
received death threats on a regular
basis but everybody who's freedom-loving
should love the Second Amendment owning
a rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different
started in a garage by a Marine veteran
more than two decades ago
Bravo company manufacturing BCM for
short builds a professional-grade
product which is built to combat
standards
Bravo company manufacturing is not a
sporting arms company they design
engineer and manufacture life-saving
equipment the people at BCM assume that
when a rifle leaves their shop it will
be used in a life-or-death situation by
a responsible citizen a law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas to learn
more about BCM the folks that are
fantastic head on over to Bravo Company
MFG comm you can discover more about
their products special offers and
upcoming news that's Bravo Company MFG
comm you need more convincing find out
even more about BCM and the awesome
people who make their products at
youtube.com slash bravo company us egg
and that's youtube.com slash Bravo
Company USA okay so let's talk for a
second about whether it is true that you
are not in control of your own life in
the United States so this is the
contention of people right left and
center these days is that basically the
American Dream is dead and now
government is going to restore the
American dream to you with
interventionism it's absolute crap okay
so one of the things that we keep
hearing for example is that income
mobility is declining radically in the
United States this is effectively not
true the income mobility has not
actually changed in the United States
since like the 1970s hey that that is
true as of The Economist February 1st
2014 hey America is no less socially
mobile than it was a generation ago
there's this misperception also when
when you talk about people working two
jobs that people work two jobs forever
that whatever is the job you hold today
will be the job you hold tomorrow
there's no time horizon on economics in
the view of people on the left and
people who want government intervention
ISM where you are today is where you
will always end up nonsense absolute
garbage when people talk about the
difference between the 1% and the 99%
for example what they are missing is
that people move in and out of the 1%
they're also missing that the 1% is
disproportionately older why because old
people
are just richer no because they spent
their life building up wealth and
building up careers if you're working
two jobs today there's a good shot then
in ten years you won't be working two
jobs if you are working a job for 50
grand today there's a very good shot
that in ten years you will not be
working a job for 50 grand you'll be
working a job for 75 or 100 grand income
mobility is still present in the United
States if you want to know why certain
areas of the United States suffer from
lack of income mobility it's not because
of the government it is because almost
purely not almost purely but largely
largely is because of personal decision
making income mobility declines
radically when you make bad decisions
okay again this does not mean it's a bad
decision to work two jobs as I say often
that's a fantastic decision to work two
jobs what I'm saying is that if you make
a decision to have a baby out of wedlock
for example or to drop out of high
school or to not work a job turns out
you're not gonna get ahead I know lots
of billionaires lots of them
I don't know a single billionaire really
who grew up a billionaire not one I know
they're kids but the billionaires
themselves I mean I could tell you
stories I know billionaires who grew up
so poor oh and make your head spin
I mean rich people who grew up because
the American Dream is that you will be
able to rise over the course of time so
you're working two jobs to put a roof
over your head right now is not an
indicator that you will be working two
jobs forever in the United States also
it is simply not true as I said
yesterday on the show in the part that
everyone wants to ignore that tons of
people in the United States are
desperately working two jobs in order to
put a roof over their head everybody who
is doing that is making a freely willed
decision to do that and good for them
good for them you can't change that by
rejiggering the economic status at the
top by the by the Democratic Party a
wealth tax ain't gonna fix that problem
because that problem is endemic to labor
supply and demand you're not gonna make
a job that is worth 750 an hour worth 25
bucks an hour simply because Elizabeth
Warren says so but it is worth noting
that the United States is not suffering
from a vast plague of people who must
work two jobs in order to get ahead in
fact aoc made that claim just about a
year ago and that claim was simply false
she said unemployment is low because
everyone has two jobs unemployment is
low be
people are working 60 70 80 hours a week
and can barely feed their family
this was rated pants on fire by
PolitiFact KF politifact ever gives a
democrat pants on fire you know that it
was just completely false according to
PolitiFact multiple job holders account
for a tiny fraction of American workers
again what you're hearing from Democrats
is that it's everybody so we have to
dramatically rescale the economy that's
not going to work number one and number
two it is not everybody in fact it is a
very very small percentage of American
workers as held by PolitiFact okay left
wing soars it is also not true that
people are working 60 70 80 hours a week
to put food on the table as a general
rule the Bureau of Labor Statistics
according to PolitiFact breaks down its
count of people with multiple jobs into
three categories people working one
full-time job in one part-time job
people with two part-time jobs and
people working two full-time jobs a
worker with two full-time jobs is the
smallest category of the three the
people who might be working 70 or 80
hours a week amount to a tiny percentage
of a tiny percentage 310 thousand people
at most in a pool of employed Americans
totalling 150 million it's also worth
noting that on average Americans aren't
working more today than they have been
in the recent past the average number of
hours worked in the private sector has
hugged tightly to about thirty four
point five hours a week since 2006
except for a dip during the Great
Recession and so all of this the table
setting by the Democratic Left that
America has no more income mobility that
everybody is working 80 hours and two
jobs it's just not true it's just not
true and we'll get to another myth of
the left which is that we don't spend
any money trying to help people who are
in poor economic circumstances that is a
lie as well we'll get to that in just
one second first these days a lot of
workplaces offer employees some pretty
nice perks it turns out daily wire is
actually a pretty nice place to work we
offer people workplace snacks every so
often they get to go home spend five
minutes with their family come right
back here one of the perks at some
companies is life insurance but you
don't really want to rely just on your
workplace life insurance this is where
policy genius comes in policy genius is
the easy way to shop for life insurance
online in minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find the right
amount of coverage at the best possible
price if you have workplace life
insurance the
policy genius team can review that
policy and let you know what additional
coverage you might need
so remember workplace life insurance
policies and I like workplace and ass
you know they're good for what they're
good for
but they're not quite good enough be an
adult go get the level of life insurance
that is necessary for your family to
have in case god forbid something
happens to you we've been talking
personal responsibility the whole show
one aspect of personal responsibility
having insurance necessary to provide
for your family in case god forbid
something happens to you go check out my
friends over at policy genius its policy
genius.com find out how to supplement
that workplace life insurance and better
protects your family today okay in just
a second we're gonna get to the myth
that america doesn't spend money on
social welfare programs on helping
people out obviously that is untrue
we'll also get to the myth that
democrats are innately more charitable
so that when we say that it's your
personal choice how many jobs you want
to work or what kind of lifestyle you
want to lead and that you can find a
strategy to better your life and want to
help you out that we're not just saying
that we don't want government involved
we actually do want to help you out I
will explain statistically how this is
true from the right first gang we are
now in the homestretch they're just a
handful of days left to purchase tickets
to our backstage live show it's a
special one-night only event next
Wednesday August 21st at the fantastic
terrorists theater in Long Beach
California I'll be there daily where
god-king jeremy boring will be there
andrew Clavin will be there michael
knowles will be there we'll all be there
live and we'll be tet will be talking
politics and pop culture we'll be
answering your questions from the
audience
tickets are available at daily wire.com
slash backstage including our limited
VIP packages that guarantee premium
seating and photos and meet and greets
with all of us a gift from me I've been
shopping for it for you and more they're
selling fast head on over to daily
wire.com slash backstage get yours today
that's daily wire.com slash backstage
also while you're out of money you just
go over to daily wire and subscribe you
can just get that annual subscription
get yourself that left his tears hot or
cold tumblr I know our friends over at
Media Matters enjoy their since they
watch the show every day by the way in
terms of job creation
you're welcome Media Matters I'm
employing half your people daily
wire.com go subscribe right now when you
do you also help protect us from the
evils of nasty groups like Media Matters
trying to target this show and others
who really appreciate it we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so again the myth pushed by politicians
is that nobody can get a leg up in the
American economy it is not true
statistically speaking it is also untrue
that the United States doesn't spend
trying to help people who are suffering
economically it is simply untrue
according to the American Enterprise
Institute the Census Bureau reported in
2016 that about 13% of Americans lived
in poverty that is impossible to
reconcile that poverty rate which has
remained virtually unchanged over the
last 50 years with the fact that total
inflation adjusted government transfer
payments to low-income families have
risen steadily transfers targeted to
low-income families increased in real
dollars from an average about $3,000 per
person in 1965 to $34,000 in 2016 per
person per year
those numbers actually underestimate
transfer payments to low-income families
because they exclude Medicare and Social
Security which provide large subsidies
to low-income retirees the measured
poverty rate has remained virtually
unchanged because the Census Bureau
doesn't count most of the transfer
payments created since the declaration
of the war on poverty which by the way
has been a large-scale fail now as for
the notion that is being pushed by folks
on the political left that's a real
nefariously the real reason that those
of us on the right very often suggest
that your life is in your own hands it's
not because we want people to help
themselves it's not because we believe
that empowerment in America is about
recognizing your own value as an
independent free human being it is not
because I've seen too many people fail
because they don't believe in themselves
don't believe in their own capacity to
make responsible decisions now the real
reason is because I'm selfish and don't
want to pay higher taxes let me explain
Republicans give way more in charity
than Democrats do and it's not charity
Democrats when you are not taking the
money out of your own pocket it doesn't
count as charity when you're taking
money out of my pocket that be you
stealing my money from me it's charity
when I give the charity out of my own
pocket which yes I do and every other
Republican I know does too and this is
not this is not anecdotal this is
statistical paul sullivan writing in The
New York Times November 3rd 2018 red
counties which are overwhelmingly
Republican tend to report higher
charitable contributions than Democratic
dominated blue
according to a new study on giving and
then watch how the New York Times tries
to backfill this
although giving in blue counties is
often bolstered by a combination of
charitable donations and higher taxes so
in other words they're now going to
count you taxing other people as
Democratic charity well isn't that nice
I wish that I could count me voting to
take your money and give it to a third
party as charity that seems delightful
frankly it seems like I'd be able to
really get around this whole trying to
be a good person and give charity out of
my own pocket things simply by taking my
business partners money and giving that
to charity
that sounds pretty fantastic well this
brings us to the end of this particular
very long rant about economics in the
United States suffice it to say in
summary your life is in your hands
solve your own damn problems because
they are your problems and you are the
solution to your problems not Camille
Harris not the government that's the
point and if you believe differently
you're gonna live a much harder life as
a general rule because your ability to
control all of society to your liking
and in a moral fashion by forcing other
people to do your will by bending them
to your will and that is unamerican it
is unamerican to force other people to
create the utopian situation for
yourself against their will that you
wish it is wrong it is morally wrong
there are certain things people do that
are wrong to each other engaging in free
and open exchange is not one of those
things if you want to make your life
better
do it do it and it's not gonna happen
overnight doesn't mean that your choices
are free right now I'm not suggesting
that you can go from working at
McDonald's to being a billion or
overnight nobody has ever suggested that
nor would they because it's idiotic what
I am suggesting is that in a free
country where we should all be grateful
to live it is not a sign of elitism in
fact it's a sign I think of populism to
say to folks do your own will make
yourself the center of your story and
the hero of your story okay meanwhile
let's talk a little bit about the insane
media bias that surrounds every major
event in the United States not just take
me out of context and throwing me on
Twitter for the boo box but you know the
actual insane media bias that pervades
the the system so yesterday there was
this horrible mass shooting
in Philadelphia and everybody decided in
the media to jump to conclusions
so CNN had on this representative who
immediately before any of the facts were
out we didn't know who the shooter was
we didn't know the situation immediately
started assuming this was about gun
control the representative his name Val
Demings and said I think we can assume
you know without any evidence that this
was probably high-powered rifles I doubt
very seriously that if this shooter in
Philadelphia was armed simply with the
handgun that this gun battle would be
going on well beyond an hour I think we
can assume that he is also heavily armed
with high-capacity rifles or weapons and
also has high-capacity magazines we need
to get these high-capacity weapons and
magazines off of our streets more gun
laws that's the solution and CNN totally
agrees Wolf Blitzer use the ongoing
shooting to pitch Kamala Harris's gun
control program again none of the
information was actually about about
what happened here but Kamala Harris
openly suggested that her solutions on
gun control would have stopped the mass
shooting in Philadelphia before she knew
what the hell was going on we need
Congress to act we do not lack for good
ideas we do not lack for tragedies the
failure of Congress however the United
States Congress to act on passing smart
gun safety laws is is is the issue
so when elected I'll give the United
States Congress 100 days to pull their
act together on this and put a bill on
my desk for signature and if they do not
I am prepared to take executive action
to one put in place a comprehensive
background check requirement to put the
resources into the ATF to take the
licenses from gun dealers who violate
the law and three to ban the importation
of the photo just to be precise you want
to give Congress a hundred days and then
take the executive action some people
say you know what Congress given the
sixty votes needed in the Senate not
gonna do it why not take executive
action on day one
well I believe in giving people a chance
especially when they know what's coming
if they don't act she would have stopped
it you know and she would have stopped
it
shouldn't he know what was going on well
now we know what was going on here is
what was going on in Philadelphia quote
from the Philadelphia Enquirer police
sources identified the gunman in a
standoff at a Tioga apartment building
that left six police officers injured as
Maurice Hill 36 he's not really a mass
shooter as we will see hey Phil
Delphia man with a lengthy history of
gun convictions and of resisting
attempts to bring him to justice
wait wait you mean a guy with a bunch of
gun convictions for violating gun laws
had guns and used them to shoot police
officers you know what I solved this
more gun laws obviously if somebody just
keeps shoplifting over and over and over
what we need is a new shoplifting law
not better enforcement not more guards
what we actually need is more
shoplifting laws because if a serial law
breaker realizes that we've stacked up
one additional law then probably they'll
stop probably this guy would have
stopped if you just know like if we had
an assault weapons ban probably this guy
never would have violated another gun
law despite the fact that he'd violated
six of them
the police sources declined to be
identified because they were not
authorized to speak the standoff began
Wednesday about 4:30 p.m. when the
narcotics strike force unit attempted to
serve a search warrants at a house so
great it turns out that what this really
was was it was a drug arrest gone bad
and that the person who was responsible
for the shooting was in fact a serial
offender but we are gonna get talk about
gun control nonetheless in fact the the
mayor of Philadelphia came out and
suggested gun control as a solution
despite the fact that again there's
plenty of gun control
this guy's a serial gun offender he
didn't care about violating the law our
officers need help they need help they
need help with gun control they need
help with keeping these weapons out of
these people's hands
I've told you earlier the two little
boys that were officer had his head
graze just a little bit more and there
was two little boys were brought out
because some because this government
federal and States in trouble don't want
to do anything about getting these guns
off the streets and get them out of the
hands of criminals okay so yeah yeah
more gun laws that that'll probably
solve it it can't be the fact that the
elected District Attorney in
Philadelphia dynamo Larry krasner he's
made it his entire mission to release
prisoners from jail and all the talk
about criminal justice reform people
tend to forget that when you release
criminals from jail many of them go back
to being criminals Philadelphia magazine
had a piece on this going back just
about a week and a half ago or a couple
of weeks ago is it what a couple months
ago rather is June 27 2019 it was an
interesting social experiment what
happens in a major metropolitan city
like Philadelphia when you elect a
district attorney
whose primary goal is releasing
criminals rather than prosecuting them
the results however were all too
predictable the unrelated violent crime
is rising in Philadelphia the police
force is demoralized victims of crimes
their families advocacy groups feel
betrayed this should come as a surprise
to absolutely no one when he was running
for District Attorney krasner Larry
krasner supported by a PAC funded by
George Soros made his commitment to
social reform and reducing the inmate
population quite clear he promised to
fundamentally transform the city's
criminal justice system no one can
accuse crasner of not following through
he's funneling an increased number of
gun cases to a court diversionary
program called accelerated
rehabilitative disposition in 2018
Krasner's first year as da 78 cases were
sent to this program compared with 12
the previous year why does this matter
because criminals who carry guns usually
intend to use them why look at that it
turns out that soft on crime policies
tend to have soft on crime effects who
would have thought that but very
important the media got Kamala Harris
out there spouting her gun control
nonsense for those who don't believe by
the way but the media are biased that
presents you PolitiFact okay so I quoted
PolitiFact earlier to demonstrate that
even left-wing sources recognize the
stupidity of suggesting that everybody
in America is working two jobs but
PolitiFact is in fact a terrible source
on left-wing listen to this headline
listen to this headline hey the headline
is this new Kamala Harris and Elizabeth
Warren called Michael Browns killing in
Ferguson a murder legally it wasn't how
much should this word choice matter oh
so you're not a fact-checking site
you're a site that
actively undermines fact checks that's
what politifact means well done media
you know they're just excellent it is
amazing to me by the way that Kamala
Harris still has not been asked publicly
about the Michael Brown tweet right she
suggested that Michael Brown had been
murdered and as I pointed out this has
rather dire ramifications for a lot of
people in the United States who then
have a perverse view of how policing
works but nobody has asked her that
fortunately somebody did ask her about
Steve King's latest dumbass comments so
Steve King the congressman from Iowa who
says something ridiculous every five
minutes I've maxed out to his opponent
Kevin Feenstra you should too in the
fourth congressional district in Iowa it
didn't stop Twitter from trying to link
me with King yesterday in any case Steve
King said something very dumb yesterday
about rape and incest he was trying to
make the case that that there should not
be abortion available in cases of rape
and incest a case with which I agree and
then he made it in the dumbest possible
way here's what King had to say because
it's not the baby's fault
there's no about this what it was okay
and what if we went back through all the
family trees and just pulled those
people out there were products of rape
and incest for their beginning
population of the world left if we did
that considering all the wars and all
the rape and pillage that's taking place
and whatever happened to culture after
society I know I can't certify that
they're not part of a product of that
this is what we call a very dumb comment
so here is Steve King suggesting that we
are all products of rape and incest
which seems to be sort of excusing both
rape and incest as crimes which of
course is the stupidest thing ever so
calm O'Hara's naturally gets asked by
Wolf Blitzer about that but he didn't
ask her a single question about Michael
Brown this allows her to talk about how
crazy Steve King is which is obviously
sport for most people at this point but
again Tamla Harris gets asked about that
but then she's got PolitiFact saying
that it doesn't matter that she openly
lied that Michael Brown was shot to
death in Ferguson in a murder it's
unbelievable I mean you have to play the
wolf blitzer clip it's just it's just
unbelievable the hypocrisy okay
meanwhile in other news there's a big
hubbub that is brewing today because
Israel has now denied entry to
representative Zohan Omar and
Talib Omar and to leave are both backers
of the anti-semitic boycott divestment
sanctions movement they're both hands
high Semites the BDS movement is a
movement to destroy the State of Israel
its founders acknowledge as much so a
few things on this we have to separate
out the legitimacy of Israel banning
Omar and Talib entering as a legal and
intellectual matter from the PR effect
of it so as a legal and intellectual
matter Israel allows critics in all the
time in fact there are many critics who
are in Israel Israel has Arab parties in
the Knesset many of those Arab parties
have in the past openly called for the
destruction of the State of Israel so
it's not that Israel can't take dissent
Israel takes an enormous amount of
dissent all the time the question is do
you have to let somebody into your
borders who has essentially claimed that
you should not exist and as an
intellectual matter the answer is of
course no the United States has no
obligation to bring somebody in from
abroad who is making the case that the
United States ought to be destroyed as a
sovereign entity the United States has
every ability to be on people like that
and in fact Britain does this on a
fairly regular basis except they more
broadly apply it to everybody they don't
like it's not it actually is more of a
free speech in Britain than it would be
here so as just an intellectual matter
barring people who claim they want to
boycott Israel from borrow it from from
entering Israel doesn't seem like that
big a deal is an intellectual matter and
it's not a violation of free speech they
are not citizens of the country they're
calling for the destruction of the
country it is it is pretty obvious that
free speech does not encompass inclusion
of people calling for the destruction of
the entire system okay that is true
under virtually any definition of even
American free speech if you go out there
and you're calling for the violent
overthrow of the American government you
could be prosecuted for that that is
that is long-standing American Supreme
Court law in any case is it really a big
deal that Talib and Omar won't be able
to enter well not really on an
intellectual level and president Trump
of course is happy he encouraged Israel
to bar Omar and Talib it appeared before
that Benjamin Netanyahu the Prime
Minister of Israel was going to allow
them they were going to do that a little
propaganda trip around the judea samaria
area and the gaza strip blame israel for
everything they'd go home they'd fuss
about it that would be the end of it now
this is and then
apparently sounded off and said he
didn't want them coming maybe that is
because Trump again wants to use them as
the face of the Democratic Party
maybe he wants Nancy Pelosi and the rest
of the Democrats to swing behind Omar
and to Leoben against Israel maybe he
wants to polarize that more which brings
us to the second point is this a smart
move by Israel no it's a very not smart
move by Israel it's a very not smart
move by Israel this is going to result
in what we call the Streisand effect so
if Omar and Talib had just gone to
Israel and then they had done their
little propaganda tour about how Israel
is evil and shouldn't exist then their
ten fans would cheer and everybody else
would sigh and roll their eyes now
they've elevated that beyond this this
is actually giving Omar and Talib what
they want in terms of PR so they can
falsely claim that Israel doesn't
tolerate dissent and that of course is a
lie but it does give them what they want
they will go around claiming this this
price had an effect of course is where
you bring attention to an issue you
desperately don't want to bring
attention to and this is Israel making a
pretty large mistake again on an
intellectual and moral level they have
no duty to bring in Omar and Talib on a
PR level it's a big mistake
deputy Israeli Foreign Minister CP Jota
Jota vely said that the country would
not quote allow those who deny our right
to exist in this world to enter
holtsville he called it a very justified
decision it's unclear when Israeli
officials made that final decision Kevin
McCarthy the house Minority Leader said
I think would be helpful for anyone that
has an opinion to come to the country
most people believe again that it is
unhelpful for Israel to bar the sitting
Congress people but Trump was
encouraging it he tweeted out it would
show great weakness if Israel allowed
representative Omar and representative
to leave the visit they hate Israel and
all Jewish people there is nothing that
can be said or done to change their
minds they are a disgrace I agree with
pretty much all of that except the part
that it's weakness for Israel to allow
them to visit again it's a PR blunder
for them to give Omar and to leave what
they want which is to make the State of
Israel look intolerant when they really
are not democratic lawmakers of course
jumped right onboard gym climber tweeted
yes this action is antithetical to our
country's shared democratic values that
are the basis for a strong bipartisan
alliance yes I'm sure
okay I'm sure that if a sitting member
of the committee Israeli Knesset called
for the violent destruction of the state
of the of the United States
called for the destruction of the United
States as a sovereign entity I'm sure
Jim Clyburn would be up in arms if they
couldn't visit AJ's Street of course
sounded off but who cares what they have
to say because they're damned liars
anyway again bad PR move but not morally
unjustified ok time for a quick thing I
like and then we'll get to a thing that
I hate so thing that I like today
every so often Trevor Noah actually is
funny he's on Comedy Central
he was talking about Chris Cuomo and
Fredo Gay and Trevor Noah who is black
pointed out to Chris Cuomo that no
calling somebody Fredo is not the same
thing as calling them the n-word yo
Chris Cuomo doesn't mess around now I
see why CNN makes people fight in
separate boxes that's just workplace
safety yeah home was like if I wasn't in
this box I'd smash your face and look
Cuomo was clearly pissed off because he
feels like when this guy called him
Fredo it's a negative Italian stereotype
all right what's funny to me though was
that his reaction that he chose also
seemed like a negative Italian
stereotype he's like what you say I work
your story down these stairs big man you
want to talk to me you want to talk to
me fair ok time for a quick thing that I
hate so everything about this Jeffrey
Epstein death seems to be almost
tailor-made for conspiracy theorizing so
we now have reports that there was
corruption inside the jail that both of
the guards were asleep at the time of
his suicide and then falsified their
logs and now we have a story on the
autopsy excuse me this is reported by
LMT online in an autopsy found that
financier Jeffrey Epstein sustained
multiple breaks in his neck bones
according to two people familiar with
the findings deepening the mystery about
the circumstances around his death among
the bones broken in Epstein's neck was
the hyoid bone which in men is near the
Adam's apple
such breaks can occur in those who hang
themselves particularly if they are
older according to forensic experts and
Studies on the subject but they are more
common in victims of homicide by
strangulation the experts said or no so
more questions about Epstein's death
well there's a story that was very
vaguely worded about
hearing shrieking down the hall in the
middle of this who's unclear who is
doing the shrieking was it guards was it
fellow inmates was it Epstein himself
while he was hanging himself and I am
NOT a believer in conspiracy theories
this is a very weird fact pattern the
medical examiner the chief medical
examiner in New York has still listed
the cause of his death as pending and
they didn't comment on the injuries
found in the autopsy a lot of people are
speculating about this I am NOT gonna
speculate about what happened here but
again this is like tailor-made for
conspiracy theories at this point also
things that I hate this pain thing so
apparently in Geoffrey Epstein's New
York mansion there is a painting of Bill
Clinton in a blue dress which I can only
assume is meant to mimic Monica
Lewinsky's blue dress pointing at the
what would be the camera if it were a
picture pointing at the observer in red
shoes lying seductively across a lounge
chair basically confused confused not
sure what this was supposed to be but
how is this just question how how I mean
for decades everybody knew exactly what
this guy was how and the only answer is
that he was probably rich and powerful I
mean that that's the only answer I can
come up with because apparently he was
given all sorts of special privileges by
the New York authorities the federal
authorities kind of sweetheart deal with
him even though there's controversy over
how sweetheart it was this is some weird
bleep man
and it also sort of suggests that
Jeffrey Epstein and Bill Clinton were
closer than was was commonly speculated
there will be more shoes to drop here I
hope all the shoes drop all the
information should get out there as soon
as possible all righty we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you